Nikki Haley and Ron DeSantis, Trump's
top rivals for the GOP
presidential nomination.
They're heating up their attacks on him
on the campaign trail.
They're not attacking him.
On January six, new polling
shows less and less GOP voters
who are fewer
think Trump was responsible for the riot.
And a new Washington Post
poll finds only 14% of Republicans
believe he has a great deal
or good amount of responsibility.
And that's a drop from 27%
just two years ago.
Today, Nikki
Haley will be in the early
voting state of New Hampshire,
while DeSantis focuses on Iowa.
And their big push comes
just 12 days before the Iowa caucuses.
As Trump continues to dominate the polls,
we have a countdown clock.
Steve can turn on notes
about the countdown clocks
he can turn to joins us
live, starting us off this hour
from Iowa.
We all are aware that it is almost time.
Nikki Haley, Ron DeSantis out
with ads targeting
one another, taking some swings
at Trump last night
in their town halls and their events.
Are we seeing movement on the
ground before these caucuses?
Well, we'll
find out in 12 days, Phil,
whether or not
these caucus goers here in Iowa
are moved at all by these
these overtures from DeSantis
and Nikki Haley.
They have struck this balance
where they have decided
that they cannot overtly attack
Trump on one of his biggest
vulnerabilities, this
the January six riots.
These ballot problems
he's having getting on the ballots.
Instead, they've actually defended him.
And in fact,
in the last couple of weeks
to Santos and Haley have said
they would even pardon Trump
if it got to that point.
But here's one area
they have challenged
Trump on, is that his decision
to not show up to any of these debates.
DeSantis and Haley,
of course,
will appear at our CNN debate next week
just ahead of these Iowa caucuses.
Trump will not be there again.
Instead will be holding
counterprogramming on Fox News.
Here's what the is said on Fox
News himself about this, about Trump
deciding to duck, to debate once again.
Why shouldn't he have
to answer questions?
I mean, he's running on things
like deporting illegals
and building a wall.
But he did that in 16
and didn't get it done.
So I think he owes
answers to those questions.
He has not been willing to do that.
Obviously, if you go by polling,
it hasn't hurt.
But I think
now that we're in the new year,
I think voters
do expect you to answer those questions.
I think Iowans expect you
to show up and debate.
The scientists will be right behind me
at this community center in Waukee,
Iowa, later today,
where he will be trying to convince
Iowans that it's time to move on
from Donald Trump,
that this inability to
or unwillingness to debate
is a character flaw.
And it shows that he is not ready
for the challenge of
going up against President Biden
and carrying the mantle
for the Republican in another election.
Phil?
All right, Steve Cantorial for us
live in Waukee, Iowa. Thank you.
And Ron DeSantis and Nikki
Haley take questions
directly from Iowa voters
in back to back events.
The CNN Republican
presidential town halls moderated
by our own Kaitlan Collins
and Erin BURNETT.
They are live tomorrow night
starting at nine Eastern.
New developments this morning in former
President Trump's battle
to stay on the ballot in Maine.
Trump formally appealed
to the state
superior Court Tuesday
to reverse the decision
by Democratic Secretary of State
Gina Bellows,
who determined Trump
is an insurrectionist
and is constitutionally barred
from appearing on the state's
primary ballot.
Trump's team argues
that Bellows is a, quote,
biased decision maker
and has no jurisdiction in the matter.
CNN's Zachary Cohen joins us now.
Can you tell us a little more detail
about the president's
legal appeal when it comes to Maine?
Yeah, absolutely.
The Trump
team is attacking
the secretary of state, as you mentioned,
accusing her of being biased
and saying
that she doesn't have the authority
to make this decision
to remove him from the ballot.
Now, we have to remember that
Maine is unique in that
the process dictates
that the secretary of state
is the first stop
or questions
about whether or not someone
can be taken off the ballot.
And from there,
if appealed, it goes to the court,
which is what we're seeing happen now.
But in Maine, also to the argument
that Trump is submitting here is he's
attacking something at the core
of what the secretary of state's decision
was, that he says
I'm not an insurrectionist.
He really refutes that point outright.
And that is really at the center
of this section of the 14th Amendment
that has really not just been,
you know,
the reason that the decision
was reached in Maine,
but also in some other states as well.
So now the Maine Superior Court
has about 20 days
until it can issue its decision.
From there,
it would go to the Maine Supreme Court,
which has
until the last day of this month
to make its decision.
Zach, on Colorado,
Do we have any sense in terms
of what the effect of an appeal
will actually have, what it will
set off in terms of process?
Absolutely.
If and when Trump
does appeal the Colorado decision,
which is similar to the Maine decision
and why it removed Trump from the ballot,
it would essentially jump
the Maine decision in what it would be
because it would go directly to the US
Supreme Court.
And look,
any decision by the US Supreme Court
would be the final say on this issue.
But that remains to be seen
if the US Supreme Court
will ultimately take up this case.
There's been mounting pressure
for them to do
so as states have been
litigating this on their own
and honestly coming up
with a variety of different views
and opinions on it.
So, you know,
there are some state officials
that are even calling
for the US Supreme Court
to add some clarity,
bring some clarity
to this situation with the election
looming. So closely.
One more thing.
Can you articulate this immunity
claim from the Trump team
and kind of how
they're doubling down on it?
So in the
federal case, the federal criminal case,
this is the one overseen
by special counsel Jack Smith and relates
to Donald Trump's
election subversion,
alleged crimes in that case.
Donald Trump is defending himself
by saying, look,
I should absolutely
I should enjoy absolute immunity
and presidents
should be protected
from any act,
from any criminal prosecution
on acts that they committed
or that they took
that took place
while they were president.
Now, this is a really
controversial argument,
a sweeping immunity
claim that Jack Smith himself
has forcefully pushed back
on Trump, reiterating that last night
that everything that he did
in the aftermath of the 2020 election
he was doing in his official capacity
as president
and therefore should not be able
to be prosecuted for it.
Zachary Cohen, thanks for explaining
what former President Trump
aims to win back the White House.
Despite facing those 91
criminal indictments
and countless controversies.
The Washington Post.
Really, really interesting
deep dive detailing, quote,
how Trump
reignited his base
and took control
of the Republican primary.
Now, the piece notes
Trump has turned his criminal indictments
into a rallying cry.
His GOP opposition has so far
failed to coalesce around
a single effective message or challenger,
and his political operation
has been more professional
and disciplined than the past.
Joining us
now is Isaac Art Stauffer,
national political reporter
for The Washington Post,
one of the three bylines on a very,
very good piece this morning.
He's also
the author of Finish
What We Started the MAGA Movement's
Ground War to End Democracy.
Also with us
is CNN political commentator and former
Trump White House
communications director.
Illicit affair Griffin.
Guys, thanks so much for joining us.
As I was fascinated by this piece,
because I don't
think people
remember that
when Trump announced that he was running,
it was not at a moment of
it wasn't a pinnacle moment
like the Mar a Lago room was half empty.
People didn't really think
he had a lot of juice
coming out of the midterms. What changed?
Right.
It was an unusually
weak moment for him politically.
The room wasn't half empty,
but it was kind of padded
with the front row Joes
and the kind of other
MAGA super fans
and what you were missing
were like Republican elected
officials who were or major donors
who were staying away.
And then you have to remember,
like the first thing he did
after launching was have dinner
with Kanye West and Nick Fuentes
and say he wanted
to terminate the Constitution.
So things did not get off
to a great start for the Trump campaign.
And you probably wouldn't have predicted
that this is where they would be now.
So a bunch of things changed.
One is that
the Trump opposition within the party
was kind of all
pinning their hopes on DeSantis,
and he took his time
getting into the race not until May.
And Trump really used that Head
Start to pummel
DeSantis and start
bringing down his poll numbers
and reminding Republican primary voters
what they liked about Trump.
And the other big factor, you know,
you and Steve were just talking about
what the other candidates were
and weren't attacking Trump on. And
throughout 2023, there were
there was a lot of money
spent on polling and focus groups
with Republicans.
What would work,
how what messages
could actually be effective
in attacking Trump.
And they didn't come up with a whole lot.
And that's part of the problem
that you're seeing the other candidates
struggle with now.
I mean, even things like side
by side
comparisons in policy positions,
Trump supports this.
This candidate supports
that in these focus groups
that actually backfired
on the other candidate
because the voters view
that as an implicit attack on Trump
right here.
Alicia,
I want to bring you
into this conversation
because there is this concerted effort
reported in the Post
to put more senior staff around.
Trump Right.
But this campaign is different
in terms of who is around him, right?
A lot of people
there was a kind of a mass exodus,
and I've heard that the people around him
are more sophisticated
in how they're approaching this race.
What do you know?
Well, in the sense of Susie
Wiles and Chris, lots of you know,
these are incredibly
professional operatives
who've had great success.
Former Florida GOP chairwoman
that are smart advisers.
They know when to reel him in.
When Donald Trump goes out
and says things leaning into he's
going to be a dictator
they know to walk him back.
I don't want to overstate, though,
this notion
that he's got this
really sophisticated team around him.
Beyond those two individuals.
It's probably a mishmash of folks
who've been clinging to him since 2016
or those who kind of stayed
after January six.
But those two individuals
know that keeping Trump
out of the public eye
more or less
is actually the best thing they can do.
Donald Trump is not out
giving huge rallies
in the way that he was
at this time in 20, I'd say 2020,
and we're going to see that tick up.
He's not on Twitter.
He's not giving big sit down interviews.
He's not on mainstream
media in a regular pace.
So I think the public
is kind of forgetting the chaos
and the crazy of Trump.
I think that's reflected in
some of the poll numbers
that we're seeing.
And how much he's
surpassing his challengers.
The more that people see him,
the more they're going to remember
the best operatives in the world
cannot stop Donald Trump.
They cannot convince him
to not be his own worst enemy.
They can't convince him to not say
and do crazy things.
So that's where to start
seeing more of that,
I would guess, in the
first quarter of this year.